this video is sponsored by blinkist
most of us have at least some amount of
fear around the idea of not existing of
death of course this is a fairly natural
and common fear seemingly far less
common however and perhaps at first
somewhat bizarre sounding is the fear of
existing
but arguably this fear is just the other
side of the same coin and upon further
examination Perhaps it is just as if not
more reasonable and common
once you were born there is no escaping
there is no real way out of yourself of
the cosmos of this reality not even
through death can one Escape themselves
or reality even if death is the end then
at that point there is no one even there
to escape or escape from you are either
you or nothing in all cases no one is
escaping themselves or the conditions of
this reality
and of course perhaps death is not
nothingness Perhaps it is everything
over Perhaps it is a heaven or hell
Perhaps it is another form of existence
Perhaps it is something completely
beyond our comprehension
no matter what once you are born you are
ultimately and absolutely stuck inside
this reality stricken to its conditions
and the limits of your ability to
perceive and comprehend it naturally one
is left to wonder and tremble over what
all this is where it all comes from
what's out there and around us
Howard Phillips Lovecraft was a 20th
century American Horror and weird
fiction writer who deeply knew the fear
and disquiet elicited by the fundamental
nature of our existence his work would
go on to form the philosophy known as
cosmicism which essentially argues that
there is no identifiable divine presence
or meaning in the universe and humans
are an insignificant deluded ignorant
and vulnerable species trapped within it
rather than vampires classical monsters
or serial killers the terrifying
entities and objects of fear and
Lovecraft stories are the unknown the
things we cannot perceive or comprehend
but lurk in the infinite vastness of the
cosmos behind and within our reality or
within the very nature of reality
the oldest and strongest emotion of
mankind is fear and the oldest and
strongest kind of fear is fear of the
unknown Lovecraft wrote
in a short story The Call of Cthulhu a
giant Indescribable entity referred to
as Cthulhu exists dormant deep in the
Pacific Ocean Cthulhu possesses
unfathomable power affecting various
people in groups across the Earth
destined to eventually rise up and take
control over the planet though no
character in the story can ever truly
see and comprehend it as it is only
capable of being encountered partially
through dreams works of art or in the
minds of the insane its form extending
Beyond regular human conception
like many of the entities throughout
Lovecraft stories Cthulhu is a being a
part of a group known as the great old
ones which along with other entity
groups are beings who inhabited the
cosmos and Earth deep into the past who
only partially exist in our world and
dimensional Acuity if at all and their
nature and motives are largely unknown
and unknowable
the entire mythology surrounding
lovecraft's literary world would later
become named after this entity now known
as Cthulhu Mythos
of course what makes these stories and
entities so unsettling is what they
point to about our own existence
what do we see and experience right now
that we have no idea are the results of
some being some phenomenon something
beyond our comprehension what might
await us in the future or after death
unlike the monsters that lurk in the
woods or ghosts that we can interact
with Lovecraft reveals that the greatest
Horrors are the things we'll never be
able to see or know
the forces that move the planets
seemingly impossible geometric
formations that would rip apart the mind
if perceived the beings beyond evil
Beyond hate Beyond conception that are
so above us in time and space we can
only hope they are completely
indifferent to us
in the Call of Cthulhu protagonist
Francis Whalen Thurston says I shall
never sleep calmly again when I think of
the horrors that lurk ceaselessly behind
life and time and in space and of those
unhollowed blasphemies from Elder Stars
which dream Beneath the Sea
for Lovecraft it is our awareness and
more specifically our increasing
awareness driven by scientific and
mathematic understanding that existence
becomes more and more synonymous with
the unknown and thus becomes more and
more the object of fear over time we
become increasingly aware of what we are
not aware of the scale of possibilities
for what's out there what this is what
we are where we are going
The Sciences Lovecraft writes from the
perspective of Thurston each training in
its own Direction have hitherto harmed
us little but someday the piecing
together of disassociated knowledge will
open up such terrifying vistas of
reality and our frightful position
therein that we shall either go mad from
the Revelation or flee from the deadly
light into the peace and safety of a new
Dark Age
Contemporary American horror writer
Thomas legati who was greatly influenced
by Lovecraft argues in his philosophical
non-fiction work the conspiracy against
the human race that humanity is
inherently aware of this sort of
horrific nature of existence but copes
by denying it ignoring it rationalizing
it or suppressing it through methods of
distraction Escape or striving toward
ideals it seems evident that very few
people can simply sit still children
spin in circles until they collapse with
dizziness legati writes
arguably it is here everywhere we find
Humanity's attempt to escape deny turn
away from suppress or ignore the very
nature of reality that we find at least
in part an indication of Humanity's fear
of existence
it is good to be a cynic it is better to
be a contented cat and it is best not to
exist at all Lovecraft Road
this quote though seemingly
straightforward points to something even
more unsettling and eerier about
existence
insofar as we can tell the universe
appears to be deterministic operating
and progressing through cause and effect
relationships everything that's
happening right now is happening because
something else happened that caused it
which also happened because of some
other things that happened that caused
those things so on and so forth all the
way back to the beginning of everything
every event that has ever occurred is
occurring and will occur is therefore
inevitable essentially all already
determined by the initial cause and
conditions of the universe and so from
the beginning of time billions of years
before you were born before you had a
say before your parents had a say before
Humanity had to say you were always
going to exist you are always going to
be a part of this whole thing as you
from the very beginning of everything
one can only wonder why why you why any
of us of all the things and people that
will theoretically never exist why are
we here why were we always going to be
and now that we are here what even is
here who and what's out here what's
around us that we cannot see or know
what's causing everything where are we
going
whatever it is you are now and you were
and will be forever a part of it in it
of it an appendage attached to its
Eternal Body taken along for the ride of
a lifetime
this is undoubtedly scary
existence is undoubtedly scary only
those who are most afraid don't admit
that
but in truth the best rides are always
scary
that's precisely what makes them worth
going on to push the boundaries of what
is possible to experience and feel to
face the fear the instinctual resistance
to the sense of uncertainty and
discomfort the scream and laugh and cry
and when the ride is over whether it's
for good or you are sent off into
another line for another ride we can
step off with Grace and hopefully the
remnants of a smile that was put on our
face because we were afraid but we did
it anyway
and we had the chance to
this video was sponsored by blankest
there's no question life is drenched in
difficulties from the very core of being
to the particulars on the surface of
daily life though there is never any
complete solution what can often help is
learning about others who experience and
feel similar things and better yet learn
how they have been able to better
grapple with them blinkist is an app
that allows you to more easily discover
authors and books who provide just that
with blinkist you can find and
understand the most important insights
from over 6 500 non-fiction books and
podcasts across 27 different categories
all in just 15 minutes allowing you to
explore more territory more voices and
more perspectives one great title in
particular on blinkist is you are not
your brain by Jeffrey Schwartz which can
help you better understand where dark
thoughts come from how your brain is
wired to form them and how to better
identify deal with and overcome them and
now with blanket spaces you can easily
add share and recommend titles with
friends and family making it easier to
connect over ideas with those close to
you create a space around a specific
group of friends or around a topic that
you want everyone in your life to learn
more about and with all the time saved
on blinkist you can now invest more time
in Reading complete books that you
discovered you are actually interested
in which you can do right on the
blinkist app using their audio books
click the link in the description or
scan the QR code on the screen and
you'll receive a free 7-Day trial and 25
off an annual premium blanket
subscription
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
foreign